here with reaction Fox News contributor
New York Post columnist Michael Goodwin
is with us former White House press
secretary Ari Fleischer also a Fox News
contributor here it is
Dems love Republicans when they're dead
Michael Goodwin the fact is it's true
yeah yes it's it is sad John you're
right that and as I put on the column
this all sounds similar the he's a hero
he's a genial gentleman he's a patriot
he's a great American and they said the
same thing about John McCain when he was
in his coffin but when they were alive
this same media attacked them
relentlessly accused them of racism of
you know stirring up a fomenting trouble
everywhere of going taking the country
backwards they attacked their Supreme
Court nominees with the same way that
Brett Kavanaugh was attacked so there is
a pattern except when they die then
suddenly they were the great Americans
in this case of course they are they are
being used those virtues are being used
against Donald Trump so that it's really
a double whammy for the Democrats in
this day and age they did the same thing
with Ronald Reagan John McCain re with
41 and 43 you're very close to the Bush
family you were there when they were
bludgeoning 43 I mean that was a daily I
didn't think it could get worse but it's
gotten worse you know you know let me
put this way when I die all you liberals
out there that hate me don't change what
you really think of me just say it just
be honest that's cold it'll be all right
I'm gonna give you a pass from heaven if
I'm ever invited it John you know here's
here's the one that is to me speaks
volumes and it was the New York Times
when George HW Bush's president went to
visit a trade show and saw absolute
brand-new technology for scanning
products at a supermarket nobody had
seen it before and the New York Times
story front page Bush encounters the
supermarket amazed here's the lead of
the story the career politician who
lived the cloistered life of a top
Washington bureaucrat for four decades
is having trouble presenting himself
to the electorate as a man in touch with
middle-class life this now is the man
that the New York Times and others are
holding up as a role model for all
Americans because of his goodness
because of this principle because of his
civility they mocked him relentlessly
and the thing about that story it was a
hundred percent fabrication that never
happened the New York Times wasn't even
at the event and that was not what Bush
was amazed about and the New Yor dan
Rather might have story corrected it yet
that's correct dan Rather LA about 43
fabricated information about Bush well
you know so if you're soft-spoken like
41 you're a wimp in the media's eyes if
you're iconoclastic and combative like
Donald Trump you're you know a brute and
this is unacceptable to the office so
you can't win can you and now all of a
sudden now they'd hated 43 re now they
love him now oh he's oh we take him back
in a minute
no they wouldn't they would be all over
him you know five seconds no and you
know I remember in the 2000 campaign
when George W Bush was running against
John McCain the press is all for John
McCain and I remember thinking to myself
as soon as John McCain were ever to beat
George Bush will go against John McCain
them and they did and that's the way
they always are last word Michael well
yes I mean look look at the way John
McCain was treated when he ran against
Barack Obama then he was just another
dirty Republican they loved the races
thousand that's right but by 2008 he was
just another dirty Republican now he's
dead and so it's great yeah amazing save
the lies if I ever pass away just speak
the truth just say what you really feel